OK.
Let's go to the phones.
A very crazy week and a lot of people wanting
to wanting to chat.
The number is 6 1 7 8 3 0 40 750.
Let's pick up first on our caller from the
8 0 6 area code caller from Aido 6.
What's your name where you're calling from
today?
Online.
Is it me?
Yes, it is.
All the pocket money bars at all from Colombia.
Oh, and I got wsop Ed..
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
So I haven't talked to you.
No.
You know, I had a question for you.
6'1, though.
Maybe ash-Sham us into bûnös.
AQuantive, Demba.
All in on it.
Come on, man.
You see?
No, no, no.
I'd rather speak in, you know, in Spanish.
You know, cause, you know, I'm trying to learn.
I mean, not in Spanish, but in English, too.
The last time you called, I thought that you
were fake and you didn't really speak Spanish,
but I guess you do.
Oh, yes.
You know, I'm speaking on this, honest.
You know, my my wife and I are trying to learn
English, you know.
So, you know, I'm just trying to speak here
right now and I get it a lot from watching
you.
Mr. Wound Up it own Dumisani.
Funny case you that in Colombia was.
Also, that carpet on the right.
Anyway, capital.
Oh, seriously?
Commerce is good.
While capital equals.
Oh, that's okay.
Well, anyway, so.
So my reply.
I'm telling you, here's why I'm doubting Pedro,
because any Spanish speaker would know it's
lack capital, not il capital.
And they would know what the capital of their
home country is.
You know what I mean?
Oh, no, that the name of the city, you know,
the copy title.
I'm sorry.
That explains a lot.
If that explains a lot.
Oh, yeah.
It confuses a lot of to me.
I was confused, so.
Okay.
Anyway, so I'm seeing the election going on,
you know.
Yeah.
We've already.
Well I couldn't vote.
You know.
I guess so.
I'm gonna worry, you know, cause I don't know
how that the convention is going to go on.
You know, cause I don't know how you can do
it.
When everybody said, you know, everybody shows
up and then and then Joe Biden, he catches
a cold or a virus, you know.
So I'm kind of worried.
Do you think they're gonna like do it over
the Internet, you know, or by a phone call?
You know, I have no idea.
Pazira But, you know, our team is looking
for a new capital in Colombia and we're not
finding it with which province is that?
Oh, you're nice piano, Mr. Black One, you're
not.
I haven't been there in a while, you know.
Oh, my.
I'm I have to get back to you on that.
But, you know, you don't know what influence
you're from.
Oh, yeah.
You do know.
No, no, I do not like.
Not right now, you know.
Huh, Pedro?
This is very interesting.
I'm going to let you go.
OK.
We're really having a tough time figuring
out, is Pedro really a Colombian guy or is
he trolling?
Last time people were convinced he was trolling.
He said he's from El Capitated.
We can't find El Capitan in in our very cursory
search.
I don't know.
I either.
Pedro is a very good subtle troll or something.
Something
else
is
going on.
I
don't know.